hurricane ida devastated louisiana one
month ago and many people are there are
still suffering fema has approved nearly
500 000 applications for disaster
assistance totaling more than 638
million dollars but that covers only
part of the need in that region where
families are still very desperate for
help our lead national correspondent
david bagno met with one of those
families he's in dulac louisiana with
more on this part of the story david
good morning to you
good morning from cajun country my
friend listen this started with a call
from the representative tanner mcgee who
represents this area he said david we
need some cbs news coverage because the
federal help from fema
is not coming fast enough
we spent the last three days here talk
about hard hit terrebonne parish we're
surrounded by the louisiana cajun bayous
and we spent the last three days
following around a single dad and his
daughter
who are sleeping
in that truck right behind me
this is where sterling guidry and his
daughter bree slept last night
in this truck
it's been their bed for the last month
here or in that tent and fema denied us
today like around 2 30
and so i'm like stressed out don't know
what what to do or how to reappeal
because i'm not a paperwork person i'm a
laborer fema did not approve him to get
money to rebuild his home which was
destroyed during hurricane ida when that
tree fell right through it our little
tiny house i built from scratch every
single piece by myself
and
i'll do it again you know
guidry is a part-time fisherman and
landscaper in dulac louisiana
since hurricane ida his main job has
been just clearing off his own property
if you want something done they say you
got to do it yourself and that's what
i've been doing hi i'm david david
robinson pleasure to meet you very nice
to meet you we went to tony robinson to
ask about sterling's story he oversees
fema's federal relief operations in
southeast louisiana
we asked him when would people like
sterling who need rvs or mobile homes to
live in right now get them i would say
that we'll probably start placing
trailers sometime
in in the november time frame
that's another month
yes sir that's not the only thing that
we've got going the non-congregate
sheltering our transitional sheltering
assistants where people can go get a
hotel room today i tried to get a motel
room close by but there ain't you know
sterling told us the reason he didn't
get approved to get money from fema to
rebuild his home is because he couldn't
prove that he owned the property fema
used to require you to give him a deed
but they changed that policy just
recently you can now give them let's say
a letter from a local mayor that says
you own it or you can show them a home
improvement receipt or proof that you've
paid property taxes so sterling went
digging looking for proof even went down
to the tax office
they're closed closed until further
notice and the number was disconnected
we called fema back and that's when they
did something very rare
fema accepted this handwritten signed
letter from guidry he wrote i have lived
on the property for 31 years saying his
mother passed away but before she died
she told me that the property is mine
in the meantime i remember that they
were they hauled off my tiny house in
big sections so i went to the trash pile
this morning
and cut out part of the floor
that was still together to make my
foundation this is where sterling and
bree are going to bathe
but until it's ready
that should be enough for you my baby
they are bathing with water bottles at a
porta potty five minutes down the road
it's been hard depressing sad
it's hard on my dad and he just like
holds it in so
you know a person can only take so much
on this night look look their tent was
infested with bugs
and so they went back to the truck
for night number 29.
you can see the bugs right now
look fema has fast tracked this man's
story as early as today
we expect that fema will approve
sterling and give him up to 36 000
so he can rebuild his home
he told me david i have 200 to my name
that's it every little bit helps but i
want you to know that there are
thousands of people
like sterling in southeast louisiana
right now
every little bit helps
including picking up the trash it's been
a month since the storm gail a month
and the trash is still at the road
and david that's why it's so important
that you tell these stories because
they're facts and figures but to these
people these are real life people living
this life his daughter's beautiful by
the way i think she summed it up nicely
it's hard depressing and sad it's
heartbreaking to see he was denied when
you see how he's living thank you david
thank you very much